this episode is brought to you by block
fi block fi is building a bridge between
cryptocurrencies and traditional
financial and wealth management products
they're creating innovative products to
advance the digital asset ecosystem for
both individual and institutional
investors and its platform now manages
more than 12 billion in assets full
disclosure i became excited enough about
this company that i ended up becoming an
investor but moving on block fi that's
block fi offers a wide spectrum of
services and i'll mention just a few
here first their blockfy rewards visa
signature credit card provides an easy
way to earn more bitcoin because you can
earn 3.5 percent in bitcoin back on all
purchases in your first three months and
1.5 percent forever after with no annual
fee second block fi also its clients
that would be you easily buy or sell
cryptocurrencies including but not
limited to they have a wide selection
bitcoin ether litecoin and pax g as well
as usd that's united states dollars
based stable coins including usdc g usd
and pax blockfi aggregates liquidity to
offer seamless trade execution and
pricing block fi also offers instant ach
so you can move funds onto the platform
and immediately start trading on their
platform you will soon be able to trade
with ach meaning you'll be able to buy
cryptocurrencies directly with your bank
account and there's a lot more coming so
check it out for a limited time you can
earn a crypto bonus of 15 to hundred and
fifty dollars in value again for a
limited time you can earn a crypto bonus
of fifteen dollars to two hundred fifty
dollars in value when you open a new
account get started today at blockfy.com
tim and use code tim at sign up that's
blockfi.com
blockkfi.com tim and code tim
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance i recommended it
in fact in the four-hour body this is
more than 10 years ago and i did not get
paid to do so with approximately 75
vitamins minerals and whole foods
sourced ingredients you'd be very
hard-pressed to find a more
nutrient-dense and comprehensive formula
on the market it has multi-vitamins
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases if i miss anything
i'm not aware of of course i focus on
nutrient-dense meals to begin with
that's the basis but athletic greens
makes it easy to get a lot of nutrition
when whole foods aren't readily
available from travel packets i always
have them in my bag when i'm zipping
around right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake can
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissues
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
i'm going to keep my preamble short by
popular request
my guest today is jessica leahy that's
l-a-h-e-y you can find her on twitter at
jess leahy she is the author of the new
york times bestselling book the gift of
failure one of my favorite titles of all
time subtitle how the best parents learn
to let go so their children can succeed
and the addiction inoculation subtitle
raising healthy kids in a culture of
dependence over 20 years jess has taught
every grade from 6th to 12th in both
public and private schools and spent 5
years teaching in a drug and alcohol
rehab for adolescents in vermont she
currently serves as a recovery coach at
santa at stowe a medical detox and
recovery center in stowe vermont where
100 of her salary goes to a scholarship
fund for young adults she writes about
education parenting and child welfare
for the washington post new york times
and the atlantic is a book critic for
airmail and wrote the educational
curriculum for amazon kids award winning
the stinky and dirty show great name
also she co-hosts the hashtag m writing
podcast with best-selling authors kj del
antonia and serena bowen from her house
in vermont where she lives with her
husband two dogs
where she lives with her husband two
sons and a lot of dogs
find her on social at jess leahy on
twitter instagram at teacher leahey
facebook jessica potts p-o-t-t-s leahy
and online on her website jessica
leahy.com jessica welcome to the show i
had just had flashbacks to doing the
audio recordings for my audiobooks and
getting into those tongue twister
moments when it's just a lot of stuff
it's a lot of stuff
it's just a lot of stuff for the brain
it's just a lot of stuff for the brain
so sometimes we need shorthand
and i want to talk about shorthand by
visiting
someone who i had to look up although
the name sounded vaguely familiar albert
schweitzer he has one of the most
incredible wikipedia introductions
ludwig philip albert schweitzer
was an alsatian polymath he was a
theologian organist musicologist writer
humanitarian philosopher and physician
he received the 1952 nobel peace prize
and i asked or should i introduce him
because i believe you are fond of a
quote attributed to
dear albert and that is quote i decided
to make my life my argument end quote
and i'm not sure what that means but it
sounds promising could you
please expand so albert schweitzer
there's some problematic stuff with all
white guys from europe who feel like
they're going to go out and save people
in africa which is essentially what he
tried to do there's a hospital the
albert schweitzer hospital is in africa
and he
you know he he had been a composer he'd
done some really cool stuff and then he
went to los or went to medical school
late in life and established this
hospital in africa where he essentially
was just trying to do good for the rest
of his life again
some problematic elements there but when
my husband was in med school and i was
in law school we actually both became
albert schweitzer fellows and the idea
there was that you don't need to go to
africa and save these people across the
planet you can his hospital was in a
place called lambornais you can find
your own lamb renee and
for me that was working with kids in
juvenile court and with my husband that
was working with underserved populations
and doing hiv work
and i've just always loved that quote
because it's you know people say a lot
of crap people are out there talking
about how great they are on twitter and
the things they're doing on twitter and
and being really loud about their
intentions but i just think it's easier
to make your life your argument and just
do you know as a teacher i have to model
things for kids i'm a mom i work as a
recovery coach so a big part of what i
do is stay sober you know i mean i think
it's a lot
simpler if we just shut up for a little
while and make our life our argument
i love that decided to make my life my
argument it reminds me of another quote
that i think of a lot because i
sadly have a
sort of tasmanian devil tendency to get
very upset at points i haven't quite
mastered that whole stoicism thing yet
and the quote is i think it's george
herbert but i think that i'm probably
mixing that up because i'm thinking of
dune and frank
herbert but nonetheless the quote is
the best revenge is living well yeah and
i also
find that to be very actionable okay so
making your life your argument we're
going to double click on that in a
little bit but first i have to go back
to your bio
every grade from 6th to 12th in both
public and private schools
is there reliably for you and your
experience
a most difficult
cohort of students
most difficult
to teach mainly because it's difficult
for them to be who they are i think and
that's ninth grade for easy i mean like
so i love
sixth grade is interesting because
that's usually a new year in middle
school seventh and eighth grade i adore
i love love love 10th and 11th grade
seniors can be tough because they've got
one foot out the door freshmen are just
dear in headlights they're scared and
they're freaked and they're it's too
much and their frontal lobes are not
fully developed and it's just it's so
hard yeah i think freshmen or if i had
to
sort of black out one and it's not that
i don't adore freshmen it's just it's
hard to teach them there's too much else
going on for them to be able to cope
with the world and and learn stuff it's
just a problematic year does it and this
is a leading question but does it mean
that
good ninth grade teachers are able to
intervene or
exert an effect that has a
disproportionate
influence on someone's trajectory
at the same time or is that not so much
true oh no absolutely and there was this
one oh there's one quote i hated it was
actually you know it was i'm pretty sure
it was radio lab yeah it was radio lab
and a middle school teacher was talking
about the fact that you should just
stick middle school students like away
somewhere and then bring them back when
they're out of that middle school age
and ready to be educated
and the problem with thinking that way
is that number one is just wrong number
two
i think there are people that gravitate
towards certain age groups when i speak
to other middle school teachers i mean
middle school is my jam that's my i love
them if i was to go back to teaching
tomorrow it would be middle school i
adore them but of course there are lots
of people who are like oh my god what is
your problem that's that sounds horrible
but i look at kindergarten teachers and
i'm like i do not know how you do that
all day long there are people who just
think ninth grade is an incredible year
and the reason it's an incredible year
is there's a ton of potential because i
think
in general schools tend to overlook
ninth grade as so transitional
that a not a lot of effort is put into
the curriculum or into connecting with
the students so in a lot of schools
especially in schools where i've taught
there's no effort to sort of do
differentiated learning they don't sort
of know who these kids are yet so they
just sort of slap a lot of intro level
blah blah blah without making it very
interesting and schools that do freshman
year write are really setting kids up to
do great things the other thing i love
and i have to shout out there's a
hoity-toity wonderful but hoy d toy
private school outside of boston called
belmont hill school for boys it's
belmont hill school is a there are some
teachers there i just adore
they do the coolest thing
middle school
is seventh eighth and ninth grade so
ninth graders who are at this really
important moment in their development in
terms of their cognitive development
their physical development get to be
leaders
for just that one extra year
and the pressure of high school
doesn't quite land squarely on their
shoulders quite yet so then they get to
do that 10th 11th and 12th i love that
model and i think that there's potential
in that model that's super interesting
so then they would transfer or graduate
to a high school
but enter in the 10th grade as opposed
to in the ninth grade yeah and that
there especially it's all mashed
together but you know middle school is a
really problematic area simply because
we throw more at these kids than they're
cognitively able to do you know the last
part of the brain to hook up is the
frontal lobe that doesn't happen until
we're in our early to mid 20s middle
school we say here is lockers changing
schedules different languages i used to
teach latin class right after french
class and there's the same word in both
languages pronounced completely
differently there's hormones there's all
the different things that middle school
kids are asked to do
without the capacity in their frontal
lobes to juggle at all so the fun part
of being a middle school teacher is
sitting back and watching that unfold
and having patience with that and
waiting for those learning moments when
everything is just
like a kid is ready to hear it and
you're ready to teach it to them and
you have a meeting of the minds that's
why middle school has so much incredible
potential but at the same time there's
so much potential to screw it up in a
major way like to take the radio lab
approach and say in that one interview
anyway and say well those a throwaway
couple of years because they suck but
you know
i think there's a ton of potential not
many of my listeners will know this but
i actually
thought for a very long time that at
some point i would go back and teach
ninth grade specifically ninth grade
really so what is it you like about
ninth grade
well i i might
reframe
that or answer a question you didn't ask
since i'm practicing to become a
politician that's not true but
the the reason behind it it's not so
much that i liked ninth grade because i
can't say that was the case
but i saw
people who received
good inputs yeah go one direction and
people receive bad inputs go another
direction
and it seemed like a great point at
which you could
influence direction
because by the time it was the end of
10th grade or 11th grade at least from
the perspective of college or anything
like that it was i don't want to say too
late but it was
much harder to write the ship and so i
had you know friends who two friends who
one ended up dying in a drunk driving
accident later one who overdosed
on fentanyl and died that was my best
friend growing up
who didn't really receive
the inputs that i did just by chance
really it wasn't by design i just had
better luck
and
so that always stuck with me and i'm
going to come back to students we're
going to talk a lot about
students and kids but i want to look at
maybe some overlap and that is your
personal story and when you were younger
what was taking a nap
code for in your extended family taking
a nap meant either
that you just needed a break from life
because i there was some stuff in my
family growing up that was really
challenging for the grown-ups well for
everybody to deal with and so taking a
nap meant just i need some space but you
know i came to learn later on that that
napping wasn't just about napping it was
it was about being drunk and the problem
with euphemisms which by the way i hate
oh i hate euphemisms
is that it makes it really easy to
gaslight kids when they figure out
what's really going on and yet the
language of adults is not matching
their experience of what they really
truly are starting to understand and
there is nothing worse coming back to
middle school in ninth grade and all
that stuff there's nothing worse than
taking kid who
is just figuring the world out
and then telling them at every turn that
their perceptions are inaccurate
that what they're seeing is not really
what they're seeing or what they're
perceiving and what it does is it slowly
erodes a kid's feeling of
well sanity i mean gaslighting is is
really problematic that way but also
their feelings of self-efficacy a
feeling like
if i can just nail this down then maybe
i can do something to change it you
can't even get to the place of nailing
something down because the grown-ups in
your life are telling you that what
you're seeing is not really what you're
seeing and that's
a massive
that's a really horrible thing to do to
kids
you know if a kid comes to you and says
here's something i'm perceiving telling
them that that's not what they're
perceiving or that they're wrong to
perceive it that way is a problem is is
really tough for kids
so one example of that being i need an
app or taking a nap as code for sleeping
off
yeah being drunk or having a hangover or
or i can't deal with what's happening in
my world so i'm just going to escape
from it and you know more and more i
began to understand that what escape
really was was was being drunk that
whatever it was that was happening in
the real world was too difficult and so
therefore you you drink to escape it
what happened in 2013 at your mother's
birthday party
you really go there don't you just go
right right for the jugular no no no
it's good skipping
the niceties
i had known that i was an alcoholic for
a pretty good long time i really was
scared to death of alcohol because of
what i saw i was raised by an alcoholic
one of my parents was raised by now
alcoholic and so on and so on and so
i you know i did everything i could to
escape it and it just snuck up on me in
my 40s
i met someone the other day actually who
had almost exact same story i did sort
of went to the sober end of the spectrum
became one of those holier-than-thou
really annoying high school and college
students who was always i was always the
designated driver i was always the good
girl and da da
so slowly in my 40s it got worse and
worse and by 2013
i was on a bit of a role professionally
i had i was teaching full-time and i had
just started writing on the national
level like this was huge for me my first
article at the atlantic went viral and
it led to this massive auction i think
it was somewhere between 11 and 14. i'm
going to get the number wrong so it's
somewhere in there editors were in a
round robin auction for my first book
the gift of failure because of this
viral article that was in the atlantic
called why parents need to let their
children fail
a huge
pivotal moment in my life and books sold
in like may and then june 7th i went to
my parents house for my mom's birthday
party and tons of people were there that
had known me my whole life including my
oldest friend that i've known since i
was three
and i got so drunk i have no idea what
happened i mean i think that's a
blessing and a curse that i can't
remember anything that happened but what
happened the next i was just i was so
drunk and the next morning my dad
who
had been
a really great enabler his whole life
because he'd been raised by an alcoholic
and taught by his mother who was an
incredible enabler for alcoholism
he came up to the guest bedroom and he
put us he sat on the floor
put his elbows on the bed my husband was
out running
and he said
i know what an alcoholic looks like and
you're an alcoholic and you need help
and at that point
i was so
ready
i was so exhausted that i i just said
you're right and that night i went to uh
my first recovery meeting
but i think the fact that it was my dad
my dad who had been one of the people
who had told us no no what you're seeing
is not what you're seeing that kind of
stuff and he is so conflict avoidant
and he adores me so much and the fact
that he hates fighting with me he came
up to that room he sucked up his he you
know just swallowed down his enabling he
swallowed down his avoidance of conflict
and what he led with was his love for me
even though he was scared to death to
say those words he did and that was it
for me so
my sobriety date is june 7 2013.
wow
well congratulations
and
i have many more questions okay so i've
had someone named gabor mate on the
podcast before and
he talks a lot about asking not why the
addiction but why the pain
right and you've also mentioned and
perhaps we'll chat more about
chris but chris herron
and
he talks a lot about
not paying so much attention to
stories from or about people when they
hit rock bottom but paying attention to
what caused them to drink in the first
place or
start using drugs in the first place the
quote is and you can see it if you watch
the documentary about him called first
day the quote is
we spend a lot of time talking about the
last day
but what we really need to be talking
about is the first day and the first day
is is massively important and in your
case it's a little
harder for me to
say with confidence that i should
ask about
the origin because
i don't know how much it was internally
generated was the alcohol a salve
or an escape or was it simply inherited
environmentally by watching behavior and
you were genetically predisposed
that's a fantastic question
and
number one huge fan of gabor mate in the
realm of hungry ghosts is fantastic he
has a book about adhd and our add and
substance use really respect his work
and he's in the full-on in the trauma
camp he's full-on in the
all of this comes from our trauma and
the nice thing about writing about a
subject area where i don't really have
i'm not really in any one camp 100 so
i'm able to say well i agree with a lot
of this and some of this is i don't i'm
a huge fan i don't think 100 of this is
about trauma i think you know we have a
situation where
according to mark schooket at usc about
50 to 60 percent of the risk picture
comes down to genetics and then we have
the in between the genetics and the
environmental stuff something called
epigenetics which is how the stresses in
our life cause our genetics to either
you know turn on not turn on all that
kind of stuff and then we have the
environmental stuff including trauma you
know thank goodness for people who are
now talking about adverse childhood
experiences
for me i drank because of my anxiety
i've had anxiety disorder my entire life
my grandmother had ocd my father has a
mix sort of i guess i'm kind of lucky in
that it goes down by generation but we
definitely all are we're an anxious
people
and alcohol helped alcohol works great
in the short term for anxiety the
problem is it exacerbates it over time
makes it worse blah blah blah blah so i
drank to deal with anxiety i drank to
deal with some stuff i just didn't want
to deal with so i had the genetics i
also had the
thing i just didn't want to deal with
and alcohol made it easier
yeah alcohol does a good job of
temporarily turning down the volume yeah
but as you as you mentioned a lot of
long-term risks and
ketamine similarly is seductive in uh
being used for that subtractive purpose
it has its place
it has an application
and it has many applications but it's
it's also can be an escape
i'm fascinated by the practical
applications it it so happens that my
son one of my i have two sons 117 one's
22. the 17 year old is a huge fan of
someone else you've had on the show he's
of hamilton morris and
anne of michael pollan and we both have
read how to change your mind we both
have watched hamilton morris hamilton's
pharmacopoeia together
i think there's some really interesting
research coming out about especially
psychedelics anything that allows people
especially at end of life care to
disassociate to to step away from their
physical being and and have less fear
around dying in particular there's some
really cool stuff out there and i think
it's really important to put that work
in the context of an adult brain
and not let it bleed on over into anyone
under the age of i mean ideally 25
because that's when your brain is kind
of done but let's say forget for you
know just for giggles 21 or 18.
for sure those are very different things
and and right now i simply mentioned
that because
we're still exploring the personal story
and i'm curious if we look at the timing
of the atlantic article why parents need
to let the children fail this goes viral
and that was in was it
may you say the article published in
january it went viral and like first
next thing i knew i was on you know
national television trial by fire media
training and then you know it takes a
while to put together a book proposal
and so the books sold somewhere around
like april may something like that yeah
april may and then the birthday party
and the conversation with your dad was
the next month about a month later yeah
do you think you would have been as open
to hearing what your dad said had you
not been on the hook to
write a book and for those who don't
know with nonfiction generally you sell
the book with a proposal it's almost
like a business plan and then yeah you
have to write the book
yeah
i still think i would have gotten there
maybe not that day but i was so close
there's a metaphor i use both having to
do with prevention and
people figuring out when it's time that
they need help and that's this you know
i think of getting there is like this
hundred piece puzzle
and
my dad was piece 100
and i have been piece 100 once for
someone else
and i talked to a lot of people about
substance use and i have been peace you
know god knows 18 32 19 26
you have to have pieces one through 99
in place until before piece 100 drops so
i can't say for sure that it would have
worked on that day i was going to get
awfully close though i also knew i was
right at that moment
i was right there at that moment where i
hadn't
been driving drunk
i wasn't drinking at school
there were a lot of things i hadn't done
yet but oh my lord i was so close it was
right there it was just about to happen
and i would have lost everything and i
knew that my husband was raised in a
family with substance use disorder we
had talked about this even before he
knew i had a problem that that was not
something we would allow our children to
be raised with so if he ever had a
problem he knew that i would not allow
our children to be around that and if i
ever had a problem
he would not allow our children to be
around that either so i i would end up
divorced i mean that was easy that was
going to happen i believed him so i
think i was right at that cliff it was
like right there and i could see what
was coming
what did you find
most helpful and what did people try to
offer that you did not find helpful
what i found helpful
was
there was a woman that i i was scared to
death to go to my first meeting and
actually my first meeting i ever went to
i went far away from my house so i
wouldn't know anyone because i lived in
small town new hampshire
so i did this long draw not that long
but i did a drive to get to a meeting
that i thought would be different enough
because i was scared to death to run
into one of my students parents
because of course i was not in the frame
of mind to think about the fact that if
one of my students parents was at a
12-step meeting they probably
had similar issues in fact i did run
into one of the parents of my students a
few years later and she took one look at
me and she said
you're my worst nightmare and i said no
no no no you're my worst nightmare and
then we had a good laugh and it was fine
but i walked into that first meeting i
knew no one i sat down at a table with
other women
and
i just started to cry this had never
happened to me before i just it like
snot and tears and stuff and this woman
next to me without really looking at me
a few too much excessively just kept
pulling tissues out of her bag i don't
know where they kept coming from but she
just kept handing them to me
and i went up and i got my 24-hour chip
i was still just snot and and just tears
it was that
100
acceptance of the fact that this was
okay and normal and to be expected and
hard and that hard was part of it and
that that was okay
what has not been helpful
is rigidity within
a view of what it means to recover from
something i myself could never be a
moderate drinker i myself couldn't use
alcohol and be safe ever
if i was addicted to opiates i don't
know what would have worked for me in
terms of medication-assisted treatment
but the problem is i see a lot of people
who really need help
who are for example in my book is in the
addiction inoculation is a woman named
georgia who is
georgia by the way and brian figure into
my book in a big way and those are their
real names and they felt again like the
albert schweitzer quote that it was
really really important to make their
disaster that of their young adult life
worth something to other people so they
asked me to use their real names and
when georgia was pregnant and addicted
to opiates she used was on methadone and
she was shunned in recovery circles and
at the time she needed
people in recovery more than ever to
help her through this
they said no this is not the way to be
sober and i that is just so bogus to me
and i think it's because we're so in
love with black and white as a species
like this is the way you do it not that
way and the nice thing is recovery looks
different for different people getting
to recovery looks different for
different people and
if someone disagrees with the fact that
i can safely drink non-alcoholic beer
because boy i love beer i miss beer i
used to brew my own beer and so i drink
non-alcoholic beer and that works for me
but i've had plenty of people tell me
that i'm wrecking my own recovery path
because i drink non-alcoholic beer and i
just i wish people would be less rigid
rigidity is the answer there tim
rigidity is is the bane of my existence
so she was shunned because she was using
a replacement therapy
she was using methadone
so we're going to come back to substance
use and abusing kids i i want to touch
on
the gift of failure for a few minutes at
least and for those who are not familiar
with the book of course i think the
subtitle
does a good job of describing it but
what was the catalyst for the atlantic
article and then the book
i had wanted to write about this for a
long time but the way i write is
i write about data i write about
research i translate the science
but i do it through narrative and as a
teacher
the only narratives i had around me were
my students and i can't write about my
students that's just unacceptable so
i had wanted to write about this stuff i
wanted to write about both
how over-parenting
affects kids motivation thank you so
much dan pink edward dc you know all the
people who write about extrinsic
motivators and and motivation
long-term motivation
i wanted to talk about how it affects
you know our ability to do the whole me
how you chick sent me high flow state
all that sort of stuff but i also wanted
to know how over-parenting affected
learning and that was a big question
mark for me and a study came out of
australia out of queensland
about that very topic
and they had talked to school counselors
who provided the stories so for the
first time i was finally able to write
this thing and at that point i had
really just been blogging for a couple
of education outlets i'd maybe been read
by you know there were sort of a couple
hundred people who were loyal readers of
mine
and i wrote this thing and i said i
think i need to try to put this
somewhere and i had
i pitched it to the atlantic to my first
editor jenny gritz who's now at
smithsonian magazine i pitched it to her
on a friday and it was published on
tuesday morning
yeah and then welcome to welcome to the
digital media it was really cool in fact
one of the people at my school
read it and said
are you sure this isn't about our
students because those stories were
universal enough that it was easier it
was easy for me to tell that story
through using some of the quotes from
the research
and
for those people who are not familiar
what are some of the main
theses of the gift of failure
there are two ways of looking at this
sort of what we do to kids when we over
parent them and by over parenting i mean
by being directive overly directive by
telling kids what to do how to do it
giving them every step along the way
when we do that we not only
undermine kids feelings of self-efficacy
the way i sort of stay on top of my own
thinking around this is when my kids
were really little and they wanted to be
able to do something independently they
would tell me they wanted to self it so
that's my internal language for that i
wanna i wanna self it so i try to think
of teenagers as bigger version of
toddlers which actually is pretty
accurate and help themself it so
when we do too much for kids when we
whether it's taking away the
consequences of something like you know
if i'm trying to teach a kid about being
more organized because today he's
forgotten his homework
and then the parent swoops in the door
and has brought the homework to school
that learning opportunity is lost
obviously helping that kid become a more
competent capable self-efficacious
person
that's not happening it also
self-efficacy is one of the most
important things we help build up in
kids so it turns out that when we do too
much for kids we undermine their
long-term motivation to stay involved in
the things we want them to do we also
tend to give them extrinsic motivators
you know whether it's money for grades
or the grades themselves which means i'm
kind of screwed as a teacher right
extrinsic motivators undermine long-term
motivation to do the stuff we want kids
to do like
practice piano and do their homework and
yet if we want our kids to not want to
learn math the quickest way to do that
is to pay them for their math grades we
know that through edward dc's work
so there's that motivation issue but
then
the other problem is this there's this
woman who has done work on
impact of over-parenting and being
overly directive not just on motivation
but
if you think about some of the most
effective teaching tools i have one of
them is this really cool thing called
desirable difficulties it's been around
for a while but it's really beautifully
written about a book called make it
stick from harvard university press
when i give kids
tasks that require them to do a little
more parsing to think about
stuff that's just a little bit beyond
their ability level stuff that makes
them have to sort of integrate two
topics or two concepts in order to
figure out how to do this thing
it bypasses their short-term memory and
it goes into their long-term memory and
they know it more deeply in the short
term and they know it for longer like 20
years from now they probably would be
able to tell me a little bit about that
concept
the kids that can't benefit
from desirable difficulties are kids who
get frustrated and give up
and the kids who get frustrated and give
up are kids who have
really directive parents
if you have a parent who's been like
okay sweetie here's exactly how you do
it i'm going to give you every single
step and oh no no not that way no no no
do it this way
those kids have less
comfort with frustration
and if a kid can't go on to complete a
task there's this woman named wendy
grolnick has done beautiful research on
this kids who had highly directive
parents were a lot less likely to be
able to complete a task that required a
kid to kind of get frustrated and sit
with that frustration and push through
whereas kids who had what are called
autonomy supportive parents
parents who
let the kid kind of
struggle a little bit to come at it
another way and get comfortable with
that feeling of frustration those were
the kids who were able to complete tasks
that were difficult for them
so
overparented kids
tend to learn less in my classroom
using the tools that work best for
learning
this sort of the shortest way to put
that
i have all sorts of follow-ups and just
to put my cards on the table it's in
part because i am soon hoping to begin
building a family with my significant
other i have no kids currently that i'm
aware of and so
i am looking to take as many notes in
advance as possible and
one aspect of
i suppose over parenting or maybe that's
not the right label but distinctive
styles of parenting i'd love to talk
about and these may not be the right
terms but
fostering the development of real
confidence versus the shell of
confidence yeah and i've i've heard you
speak on this very eloquently and it was
very compelling so i was hoping perhaps
you could elaborate on that you know
unfortunately the self-esteem movement
kind of had
parents in like the late 60s 70s early
80s believing well and now still
actually i think believing that if we
tell our kids over and over and over
again how great they are how smart they
are how talented they are all those sort
of fixed you're so you know you just
fell out of the womb good at math that
kind of thing
that we can somehow create like a star
wars force field of self-esteem around
them so that when they go out into the
world and someone dings it because
they're mean to them or a teacher said
something that was a little difficult to
hear or whatever that somehow our kid
would come home with like perfect you
know self-esteem still intact around
them but that's not how self-esteem
works there's some really interesting
research specifically on kids with low
self-esteem
that the more we praise them for these
inherent qualities of you know that
you're so gifted you're so talented
you're so perfect all these sorts of
things
that
we actually we don't raise their
self-esteem we actually lower it
what raises kids self-esteem is not
confidence that empty sort of optimistic
my mom says i'm the best reader in the
class
but
competence which is competence with the
p which is confidence based on actual
experience on the confidence side you
know it's fun to hear you frame it this
way because
you know just the other day i was
actually those two words sort of came to
mind
in the same sentence that is confidence
and competence because i have lots of
readers and listeners ask me
how to develop confidence and the answer
is you have to go out and do things that
you are at the edge or right outside of
your sphere of comfort yeah so that you
develop that sort of increased
confidence not without any context but
confidence in your ability to execute
something with competence there's no way
around it and then if you're if you're
being told i imagine as a kid you know
you're the best at math
a b and c as opposed to you worked
really hard and you figured this out if
you can't do something there's no fix
right you're just a broken toy right
there's actually an added layer to that
which is my mo for a long time was to
advocate my way into jobs that i was not
qualified for
but i usually
i became a political speechwriter i had
no experience doing that and i got into
it the worst possible way i i read that
politician's speeches the ones he'd
published online because these are the
ones he was most proud of and i
fixed them for him that was my audition
for him i fixed his favorite speeches
for i mean it was like the most stupid
thing ever but i think that there's a
certain level of
not just i can do this specific thing
but i'm resourceful enough to figure it
out if i can't do that specific thing
and that resourcefulness
only comes from having tried something
and screwed it up and tried it again and
all that and had support throughout that
process with someone who actually
believes in your ability to be
resourceful
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know if you missed
10 of the best performing days after the
2008 crisis you would have missed out on
50 percent five zero percent of your
returns don't miss out on the best days
in the market stay invested in a
long-term automated investment portfolio
wealthfront pioneered the automated
investing movement sometimes referred to
as robo advising and they currently
oversee 20 billion dollars of assets for
their clients wealthfront can help you
diversify your portfolio minimize fees
and lower your taxes takes about three
minutes to sign up and then wealthfront
will build you a globally diversified
portfolio of etfs based on your risk
appetite and manage it for you at an
incredibly low cost wealthfront software
constantly monitors your portfolio day
in and day out so you don't have to they
look for opportunities to rebalance and
tax loss harvest to lower the amount of
taxes you pay on your investment gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account they've really
thought of a ton they've checked a lot
of boxes smart investing should not feel
like a roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you go to
wealthfront.com
tim and open a wealthfront investment
account today and you'll get your first
five thousand dollars managed for free
for life that's wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today at wealthfront.com
tim
how did writing
the gift of failure and then being on
the road metaphorically speaking or
otherwise
sharing the
findings and stories and takeaways from
the book
affect your parenting style if at all or
perhaps you are already applying the
tenets and principles from that book in
your own family i'm just curious
how your parenting
was reflective before during or after
of
things that were
emphasized in the book
the gift of failure actually came out of
me being just pissed off at the parents
of my students for stealing away so many
really cool learning opportunities
moments like where their kids were just
ready to learn and then the parent would
swoop in and fix it and then the kid
didn't have to come up with his own
strategy
and i was on a very very high horse
about that i really was i especially
because you know i'm in this noble
teaching profession and you're
ruining it for me
but i realized at the same time actually
uh one of my students wrote an essay
about the fact that she was so obsessed
with being perfect that not only
was she paralyzed when she had to write
things like rough drafts or do something
where she may not look perfect
she didn't care about learning anymore
all she cared about was what grade she
was going to get for the learning and
this was a kid that i taught in sixth
grade seventh grade and eighth grade and
somewhere we wrecked her i mean this is
this was not her fault this is our we
did something to wreck this because we
had this great sixth grade girl who
would come into my classroom and say mrs
leahy miss lee what are we going to
learn today or miss leahy miss lady
guess what i learned today and then by
the time she gets to eighth grade she's
telling me that she does not care about
learning anymore that is beside the
point what is the point for her is the
grade she's going to get when she
regurgitates whatever it is she i want
her to regurgitate in whatever fashion
and you know how high should i jump
that was devastating to me and at that
exact same moment that
same week might have even been the same
day
i found out that my nine-year-old
couldn't tie his own shoes because i'd
been doing it for him
oh
yeah and and
not only could he not tie his shoes he
was so humiliated by the fact that he
couldn't tie shoes that he hadn't told
me i hadn't figured it out he was having
to sit out pe class not play with his
friends because he was wearing his
brother's boots to school because he
didn't have shoes without laces
and he was so humiliated that was 100 my
fault i did that to him because every
single time it came time to tie the
shoes it was just easier for me to do it
if i was faster tying shoes is hard
thank you very much manual dexterity
time shoes is one of the more
challenging
tasks for a young kid and yet we sort of
use it as this benchmark of like you
you're getting big and so i just kept
doing it and then you know velcro
slip-on shoes that kind of thing and
essentially what i was saying to him
every time i said oh i'll just do that
for you it'll be faster if i do it for
you was
i don't think you're competent enough to
do this yourself
and so that my lack of faith in his
ability to do it became our norm and at
that point i then had i was like a big
bucket of cold water over my head and i
was like oh man i can't come at this
from
you parents of my students suck because
you're ruining this whole learning thing
i was essentially doing the exact same
thing to my own kids
a lot of what i write about is
we're not doing this right oh look i'm
not doing this right how can i do better
and learn from it which is super fun and
a little humiliating
well better late than never right i mean
it's right well and and then we can
model that for our kids right i mean if
we change what we do as parents
we don't have to just pull the rug out
from under our kids we can say look i
thought i was doing the best possible
thing i learned some stuff and i didn't
give you enough credit and now i'm
changing because i have new information
and that's what i try to model for my
kids all the time back to albert
schweitzer's quote yeah i have a friend
who
he's just assumed i think this is
probably fair for all parents to assume
that he's just screwing his kids up in
all sorts of ways he's unaware of and so
he's like look i know i'm [ __ ] them
all up but i'm going to pay for the
hoffman process i'm going to pay for
this other thing when they're 18 they're
going to go through these following
three things to sort of unfuck
themselves and uh i've already committed
to doing that speaking of a separate
friend i can actually name
a friend named mike maples really sweet
guy and he
on a walk with me at one point shared
the two things that he would emphasize
as a new parent because i asked him some
time ago
and one of the things that he said was
optimism
oh yeah i love it
and i believe you've pointed out
research
related to kids with high
ace scores that's
adverse childhood experiences scores
showing that one of the most important
things that people can do for these kids
is teach them hope and i would love to
hear you expand on that and if there are
any particular
ways of
teaching or fostering hope that you
think work how does one do that
hope is this really cool thing that i
think people
tend to in their heads think of as
something fuzzy like oh oh balloons
bunnies
unicorns isn't that nice
it's not it is essential there are whole
books about how one of the big solutions
to intergenerational poverty is making
sure kids have one adult who teaches
them
to have the ability to not only
see that their life can be different and
then there's part two which has to do
with self-efficacy that they have the
power to make it be so
in fact that definition of hope comes
from a guy named shane lopez a guy i
love he has died unfortunately and and i
miss him so so much but his twitter
handle is it might even still be out
there it was hope monger a seller of
hope he's just really cool guys so
according to him hope is your ability to
envision that your life can be better
different
better is i guess the way to think about
it and that you have the power to make
it so
that is incredibly powerful that when we
talk about sometimes about kids having
that one person who you know if you say
who is that one person who really made
you believe in yourself and it's
whatever a teacher a coach or whatever
it's usually because they help them
believe that their life can be better
and they had the power to make it so
those are the two sort of elements there
that are really really important and
i have a whole shelf i'm looking across
the way at an entire shelf on books on
hope and optimism and they're
intertwined in incredible ways and it's
really really important that kids have
someone
one person who lets them know
what their life could look like and
gives them that vision and helps them
sort of start to believe that it could
be so and and that's at the
center of hope and optimism i think and
something that
was consistently missing
when i taught kids in an inpatient drug
and alcohol rehab there were a lot of
kids in my classroom the vast majority
of the kids in my classroom did not have
any belief that their lives could be
different
or that they had the power to make it so
so we're going there
next or the next after next no no no
you're good you're good no no you have
to apologize we're going there next but
i should say next after next because you
mentioned the bookshelf
full of books on hope and optimism when
you need a dose of hope or optimism do
you have
one or two books that are your go-to
inoculations or i should say booster
shots
yeah they're actually sort of specific
to whatever it is i'm thinking about or
doing for writing it's stephen king's on
writing my kids use it too actually my
17 year old and i have listened to this
book in the car more times than i know
because it makes me want to write and it
makes me
find the joy again in writing it's an
incredibly joyful book it's an
incredibly useful book and it is a book
that makes me want to and i know this
sounds a little weird but turn it off
and go right and that's my go-to
book for that sort of thing and i owe
him a debt of gratitude for that book
and you have the chance to interview him
if i'm not mistaken
you lucky duck
so jealous
so jealous i i think the key to catching
stephen king's attention and getting him
to want to talk to you
is to come at something from an angle
this is something you do really well
come at it from an angle that he had and
he's been asked everything right
so what's what my angle was we were both
english teachers and i happen to know
that he loved teaching grammar so my
interview was 100 about how one teaches
grammar or as he calls it business
english and it was it was a dream come
true really it was it was huge for me
any other books that pop out when it's
uh when it's
anything outside the scope of writing
although i realize that also on writing
includes and covers a lot more than just
oh yeah it absolutely does but uh
are there any other books that come to
mind i think of them as comfort books
but they're also kind of hope and
optimism and jab in the arm kind of
books i'm a huge non-fiction reader
especially about the natural world so
like the the past year has been for me
has been just
such a
overwhelming buffet of good books about
everything from the book of eels to
of course the minute someone asks you
about books you start to blank out but
for me the thing that has brought me the
most joy especially during the pandemic
has been being outside i live in vermont
i live in the woods
there's this guy named bernd heinrich
who writes a lot about he has a book
called the winter world the summer world
he wrote a book about crows and ravens
and how smart they are for me i get a
lot of my
hope and power and
happiness from thinking about
the things i can discover out there in
the world and so they make me want to
get out of the house which is a really
really good place for my head to be when
i'm in a bad place
take the focus off the self for a little
bit yep yep yep crows are a good thing
to think about i suppose
crows you said yeah crows are cool crows
are amazing eels are cool the owls of
the eastern ice they're pretty cool
but lately that's my thing has been that
sort of natural world stuff
so hope and optimism you can listen to
your new podcast
pros and crows for a dose
vermont is spectacular i've actually
spent a lot of time in vermont i went to
middlebury college to their language
school and have spent a lot of time up
in vermont it's a beautiful beautiful
place
let's jump to
substance
use and abuse in kids what surprised you
most
in your research or what just surprised
you because most is always
like the pole position number one answer
and sometimes that's hard to sort for
what did you find surprising in your
research about preventing substance use
and abusing kids
the amount of parenting and education we
do by the seat of the pants without even
thinking about
the research about what works and what
doesn't sort of there's a lot of in
education there's a lot of this too like
this is how i was taught and so
therefore that's how i'm going to teach
it or this is what we've always done
kind of thing so there's a lot in a lot
i screwed up in parenting my 22 year old
i let him have sips i let him have his
own glass of wine at dinner research is
really really clear parents who you know
have a clear and consistent message of
no not until you're it's legal which by
the way when i say it's legal i don't
care about the legal part what i care
about is the brain development part
21 and finishing up brain development
happen to you know happen in proximity
so
things like the myth of oh but those
europeans they raise those children who
just are moderate drinkers because
it's not special to them they've grown
up with alcohol and so they totally know
how to be moderate drinkers that's not
how it works a you can't teach
moderation b
the european union has the highest rate
of alcohol consumption in the entire
world and while there are countries that
sort of do have a culture of it's not
cool to be out in public and be
drunk
a lot of the countries you think of that
we're trying to model our kids on aren't
those countries so
just a lot of stuff that i did because i
thought it was the right thing to do
when my oldest son was born a friend of
ours who really knows wine
sent us a spectacular bottle of wine
and so i put some on my kid's tongue
because i wanted my infant the first his
first taste of wine to be a really nice
bottle of wine so you know i did some
stupid stuff
a lot of the stuff that i did was
because i just didn't know any better
and so all of the writing i do is very
much from the perspective of
well yeah we screwed this stuff up
because we didn't know any better but
that's not something to be ashamed of
this is us learning to be better and p.s
i've made most of these mistakes so
let's
take this information about our kids
risks let's take this information about
what the research shows that really
works for prevention and let's actually
not feel embarrassed or shamed about
what we did wrong and just move forward
from a place of
you know knowing what works and trying
to use that
so we're going to jump around
temporarily here a little bit but what
does it mean what are your
responsibilities what does it look like
to be a recovery coach
at santa
i think it's really similar to what i
did at my rehab classroom which is
essentially being a sober person who
for better or for worse when i used to
tell my students that i was in recovery
my students would say
you don't look like an alcoholic because
people tend to have some
image in their mind whether that's of
you know someone in the gutter or
someone who's homeless or someone who
has mental illness or whatever
being a role model of someone who has
been in long-term recovery and
still struggles but still makes it work
that's sort of at its core what being a
recovery coach is it's to be someone
who's
been there and done it and has come out
the other end at least eight years on
and is able to just give people hope i
mean we're back to that hope thing i'm
modeling hope i'm modeling optimism and
i'm modeling i'm also giving them some
of the tools i've learned for me
it's really important for me if i'm
going to a dinner party to know that a
i can't worry about offending the host
if i have to leave that i always have an
exit strategy and that my husband and i
have a signal for when it's time to go
and that i just have to put my ability
to stay safe and sober first above
worrying about offending my host so
things you figure out over eight years
of sobriety and that's part of what i'm
there for
sharing the playbook what is the format
is it a group class is it one on one
how do you
impart
these lessons and model
it's both we're still shaping this santa
is is fairly new the cool thing about
santa is that it's the first
medically assisted recovery and
treatment center in vermont there just
hasn't been one and
so we're still figuring out what santa's
going to look like but the cool thing
about my job is i get to do one-on-one
and i get to do group stuff if the
people that are getting treatment are
parents and they want to talk about
prevention and their kids i get to do
that too because that happens to be my
wheelhouse um but i'm just available um
both on a regular basis in a group
setting and then as needed individually
to just talk them through stuff that's
scary and talk them through you know oh
my gosh what's gonna happen in fact i
did a talk recently
to
parents of people who work in the
alcohol industry like parents who work
in the big alcohol companies and
that's a really scary place to be
because their entire
where their money comes from and often
their social lives and the the lives
they have around their less social life
and their work life is often really
entangled and a lot of that is around
alcohol so how do you talk to your kids
so there are a lot of people who just
sort of say things like
what if i
need to go to that christmas party and
there's and i just get weak or what if i
what if my kid comes to me and says you
are a hypocrite you can't tell me about
like the fact that i can't drink because
you're an alcoholic how so how am i
going to manage that and keep safe
myself that's my job
what is medically
assisted
mean
this is sort of like a medical triage
where they can provide like saline drips
for rehydration or interventions that
involve
yeah it means a couple of things so a
medically assisted detox means that it
alleviates the symptoms of you know when
you're used to seeing if you watch like
i don't know like
some recovery show or a movie a
depiction of of someone who's going
through withdrawal or
whatever it's like you know the pain and
the sweat and all that stuff it doesn't
have to be that way a lot some people
believe that you know you have to go
through that so you'll be so scared of
going back on of having to do it again
that you won't go back on drugs but
that's just not the way it works so
medically assisted especially for
alcohol you can die going through
withdrawal from alcohol it's
it's really really dangerous so having a
physician around and actually the head
of addiction medicine at university of
vermont is the chief medical officer of
santa so you have someone there actually
monitoring you medically and alleviating
the symptoms of withdrawal so that you
can get to the place where you can even
think straight about what comes next
which is the recovery process
and dt stands for delirium tremendous
yeah that is that old term yeah it does
it means delirium germans yeah seeing
spiders and the classic things that
happen to people who
have are to the point where they need
alcohol in their system to stay alive
essentially because you can have
seizures and die if if you're at that
point in your alcoholism
why did you decide to
write a book
about this and all these things
addiction inoculation as soon as i got
sober the very next thing that happened
was
okay what about my kids because
this has to stop with me i mean i'm the
product of generations of alcoholism my
husband also has has the genetics so my
kids have it loaded up double barrel
what do i do and you know if you look at
the experts out there they say substance
abuse is a preventable public health
concern
well
what does that word preventable mean
like what does that actually mean what
can i practically realistically do
to
prevent substance use in my kids and the
eventuality or the possibility of
substance use disorder in my kids and
can we control everything absolutely not
but we do know a lot about what
contributes to a person's risk of
developing substance use disorder and so
what does the research say what works
what doesn't work if just say no doesn't
work if the assumption
is on some level that kids are going to
experiment
with sex with drugs
prior to full brain maturity
are there
any scripts or approaches
from a parenting perspective that can
help mitigate the risk or mitigate the
possible damage one of the things we
hear a lot about is that oh everybody's
doing it kind of thing that script and
what we know works for kids
what the research shows works for kids
to prevent them using drugs and alcohol
is actually having real data
a lot of parents i think like the sex
conversation a lot of parents are really
worried about talking about it will make
them do it kind of thing or like maybe
if we talk about pot they're going to
suddenly realize that pot exists and
they're going to start using it or
something like that and that's not how
it works giving kids real data on
actual prevalence how you know for
example if a kid in eighth grade is
offered alcohol and the kid says to them
you know well everybody does it it's no
big deal and that kid happens to know
that less than a quarter of kids have a
sip of alcohol by the end of eighth
grade that's
useful information that's powerful
self-empowerment information information
that helps kids feel more
like they have what's called
self-efficacy
helping kids understand before they go
off to college here are the kids who
drink here's how much alcohol is
consumed by kids in college here's this
vast majority of kids who either drink
minimally or not at all in college a
bunch of years ago i asked my students
in your most lucid and trusting
and open moment what could an adult have
said to you
that would have made you think
differently about your use or made you
possibly
reassess your use and all of them said
be honest with me
saying things like drugs are bad
is clearly a lie because people wouldn't
do drugs if they were all bad if there
was no upside why would anyone ever do
drugs so that's a lie and right off the
bat they know that we're lying to them
so why should they trust our information
giving them real information about what
it does to their brains at certain
stages of their development
helping them
focus on so for example if you have a
kid who really wants to be
an architect or a policeman or whatever
it is your kid really wants to be
and you know that they're going to have
to finish high school or finish college
or get to a certain level of achievement
in order to be that thing you can say
here's the deal we know that the
hippocampus is smaller
in kids who use pot on a regular basis
and the hippocampus is where memory
formation happens and that old joke
about people who smoke a lot of pot
having no short-term memory that's
because those receptors are right there
on and around the hippocampus and that's
a very real thing and in grown-ups
sometimes that can be temporary loss but
in kids it's more likely to be a
permanent sort of situation it can be
temporary but we also know that there's
permanent changes to the hippocampus
over time and so these goals that you
have for your life
are going to be less likely for you to
be able to achieve if you're messing
with your ability to remember stuff
bringing the data the information that
dry data about what it actually does and
how it does it and what it's doing to
your brain
when you attach it to your child's
actual goals and hopes and dreams we're
back to that hope and optimism stuff
that's how you get real leverage with
kids
and being more honest with them about
all of that who uses how much when what
it does to them that's the stuff that
actually works to keep kids making
better decisions
and actually one last thing if i could
add on this really cool thing called
inoculation theory it's a school in
sociology and psychology inoculation
theory around
helping kids
manage risky behaviors like having sex
before they're ready or using drugs and
alcohol or whatever that getting in the
car with a drunk driver
when we give kids
scripts or help them practice refusal
skills or give them a rebuttal
just knowing that they have a rebuttal
to everyone's doing it or it's no big
deal or whatever that thing is
just knowing they have a rebuttal will
make them more likely to use the
rebuttal
and
here's the coolest part it generalizes
so when we use inoculation theory to
help kids
not get in a car with a drunk driver or
not have sex before they're ready or not
use drugs and alcohol it will generalize
to all those other things which is
really cool so not only does it make it
more likely that they will use those
refusal skills they will generalize to
other risky behaviors so that's why
inoculation is in the title of the book
and why i'm so excited about inoculation
theory
dig it
question on the sort of triage side of
managing
non-ideal
circumstances so let's say a parent gets
a call from the nurse or a supervisor at
an infirmary at a given school let's
just say college
and turns out their son or daughter
has
not necessarily alcohol poisoning but
has ended up there from drinking too
much alcohol what advice would you have
for
that parent what should they do or say
or not do or not say do you have any
thoughts
the first most important thing is this
is not
about you
number one parent this is not about you
this is not your failure as a parent
this is not about you so just take a
deep breath and just sort of chill about
that for just a second
number two
whether it's
a kid who starts having sex or a kid who
gets drunk for the first time this is
not an all or nothing sort of thing it's
not like my kid is ruined because
they've gone over this black and white
border that culture has set up for them
so it's going to be really really
important for your kid to know that they
have not transgressed to the point of no
return you've not lost faith in them
you're not you know you have to listen
from a place without judgment especially
early on because the kid is going to
feel like definitely like that they've
failed you and all this other stuff and
you want to avoid going to a place of
really high emotion because you doing
that is just going to make your kid do
that and then neither nobody's listening
to each other a lot of this actually
goes back to gift of failure stuff which
is
helping your kid figure out
what was this experience like what was
positive what was negative
taking what they've learned from this
situation and carrying it forward with
them to the next time talking to them
about and making sure that they do
suffer whatever consequences are so if
the nurse calls and says your kid is
clearly feeling hungover because they
drank the night before
you going to pick them up is not going
to help the situation that's you saving
them from feeling crappy at school the
worst drunk i ever had that my husband
knew about
i had to go to school and teach the next
day and i'm so glad i did because it was
one of those pieces in that puzzle for
me it was like probably piece 97 was i
can't teach and be hungover was a really
important lesson for me to learn and i
feel like crap and i still have to
manage school is a really important
thing for you to expose your kid to
same thing with like if your kid decides
to go nocturnal and not sleep
make them go to school they have to you
know feel
because you can't teach them cause and
effect if you're saving them from the
you know from the effect that's just not
how that stuff works so those are going
to be really important listen without
judgment take yourself get your emotions
out of the equation this is not about
you and this is not an absolutist sort
of situation we can start again tomorrow
and that's been frankly for me that's a
really important part of recovery if i
were to screw up tomorrow and i very
well could i don't know the next day
comes and then i start all over again
the day after that and on a tangent
that's why i think dax shepard's episode
called seven days where he admitted to
the fact that he had relapse after 17
years
i think dax has done a ton for recovery
for being open and out about recovery
and i think everything he has done in
terms of being a role model in recovery
pales in comparison
to what he did in that episode when he
admitted to the fact that he had
relapsed and he was starting again at
day one and that he had seven days and
that he was starting over because
in an alternate universe he could have
very easily given up and i think a lot
of kids right now the anxiety we're
seeing in a lot of kids is that the
world is absolutist and you either suck
and you might as well just go
off yourself
or you're perfect and
we need to help kids see that realizing
that tomorrow is a new day and we need
to take what we learned from yesterday
into tomorrow i think i think that's one
of the most important things we can do
for kids
so you've you've mentioned or we've
spoken about you know the 100 pieces and
the
birthday party
do you have a
even outside of the realm of anything
alcohol or alcoholism or addiction
related do you have a favorite
failure meaning
yeah do you have a failure that in
retrospect is something that really
the stage for an incredibly important
lesson or learning or set up success
later and i suppose a lot of those
hundred pieces like going to having to
teach hungover could be examples of that
but does anything come to mind for you
yeah
it's not recovery related it has to do
with my writing but so i wrote the gift
failure it was my first book i didn't
know how to write a book i mean like
right knowing how to write a book is a
learned skill right so the idea that a
journalist who's used to writing 1200
words could suddenly write 70 000 and do
it perfectly the first time around
i had it in my head and my fantasy was i
would hand my first draft in and my
editor would come back to me and say
well there's no edits here i mean this
this is it this we could publish early
this is perfect what happened instead
was this i turned my book in on time on
october 31st and on november 1st i went
on a horseback ride with my husband my
friend of mine has horses that she lets
me borrow sometimes and i was thrown
from the horse and i landed on my head
and i lost my memory and lost my ability
to read for a little while it was bad it
was really bad didn't remember that i
had finished a book the day before
all that sort of stuff so i had some
post-concussion syndrome that was really
depression and stuff and then i got a
call from my editor actually i got an
email from my editor asking me to come
to new york for a talk
uh-oh no yeah that's not good and my
editor is like
i just idolized her she's like a grand
dom in publishing she's amazing
so this wasn't going to be good and i
went and what she said was this
oh god it still makes me want to throw
up
she said this book is unpublishable
she said
and then she said the worst part that
wasn't the worst part what she said was
we need to think about bringing in a
ghost
now a ghost means a ghost writer
yeah i
am a professional writer and she wants
to bring in a writer to help me write my
book
so i didn't throw up i was actually very
proud of myself for that but i i said
look
and i didn't cry which was also a huge
thing i said
before we do that and i needed some
extra time anyway because of the head
injury that really got in my way for a
while so we had some extra time to play
with
i said give me two chapters give me a
probationary two chapters and tell me
everything i did wrong
and what you want this to look like
and i filled
a notebook i sat in her office for we i
was in there for over an hour listening
to
how bad i was to how much i stank as a
writer essentially
luckily she was also lovely and she said
things like this happens with a lot of
journalists you're used to writing in
short bursts and so you end up writing
this very fragmented large thing that
doesn't hold together as a whole and
your writing is fine it's your
organization that sucks and that's what
you need help with
so she gave me those two chapters and i
went home
and i read over
a notebook full of how badly i suck as a
writer
and i digested it and i turned it into
essentially a checklist of what not to
do again
and
those two chapters turned into four
which turned into six which turned into
the whole book no ghost writer which
turned into a new york times bestselling
book that's not the best part of the
story the best part of the story for me
was that when she bought my second book
i turned that book in on time my agent
was a little nervous because she knew
i'd been a lot to handle the first time
right my editors having to like line
edit an entire book because i'm a ton of
work
but i had run my second book through the
what not to do again
to do list filter
and the book was so clean that she
wanted to move up my publication date
so wow
it's not
that i'm
a great writer it's that i was humble
enough to say
teach me how to be better i will take it
to heart and i will be able to be
objective about it and i will use it and
i won't make these same mistakes again
so when i handed in
not only gift to failure but then the
next book i was able to show my editor
that i learned from my mistakes and
it was really swedish she referred to me
in a recent email as a dream author
because i learned from my mistakes
whatever you lacked in
writing a book or organizing a book you
made up for with negotiating prowess
i'm
impressed that you had the presence of
mind to negotiate for the probationary
chapters do you remember
anything
from your not to do checklist oh yeah
anything come to mind that you can share
i would love to hear it gets really
specific i used to like the word
particularly and that's a stupid don't
use that word
also if you're ever going to record your
own audiobook really don't use the word
particularly because it's really hard
word to say
for your audience they might be kind of
boring things they're about organization
they're like my listeners are into that
kind of stuff if you're going to write a
book like the two books that i've
written
that
is about parenting kids from
preschool to college
make sure that everything is organized
in the same way so if you set up an
organizational scheme for your book
whether it's by age range whether it's
by grade then replicate that over and
over and over it's helped me become a
lot more organized in my writing and you
know it's it's really simple stuff that
i used to teach my students like if your
topic paragraph says you're going to
address points one two three and four
you don't address points three four two
and one you go in the order that you
said you were going to address them and
so come up with your own sort of style
guide for your it's not really a style
guide your own organizational guide for
your book and then make sure that every
single time you talk about whether it's
scripts for helping kids get out of
tough conversations or whether it's
i don't know how a kid's brain develops
that you're always going by the same
organizational schemata or whatever that
thing is so
just be organized and stick with if
you're gonna call something
and this was tough actually in my last
book
we're supposed to be using the term
substance use disorder not addiction not
substance abuse
but you can't say the same words over
and over and over again so you have to
come up with you know other ways to say
those things and just keep track just
keep track of what you're doing make
everything look the same over a whole
book
yeah that has been sort of politically
removed from the lexicon that you can
run into a repetition issue i could see
that hard to just pull out the thesaurus
and call yourself on it so if i'm going
to use the word addiction on the front
of my book and where and i as a
journalist i'm not supposed to be using
the word addiction in in my book i
better explain why i'm using the word
addiction which i do i use it i get very
specific
rather than run from or hope no one will
notice
address it and put it out there and you
know that makes things a lot easier for
you over the long run
with the not to do list i can imagine
particularly you're like okay got it
right check maybe not loaded not an
emotional
emotionally wrought thing to accept were
there any
that kind of stung
or that
took a second to
kind of nod and accept were there were
there any stingers if you could share
i'd be curious i've got plenty quote you
are not an organized thinker and i knew
this like i've always been a seat of my
pants
in 1200 words you can go blah blah blah
and make it all come together but you
can't do that with 70 to 90 000 words
it's just too it's unwieldy certain
tools have really helped me also by the
way when it comes to things like the
particularly thing i use scrivener to
write and scrivener will
me too i love scrivener scrivener lets
you has a word frequency counter and you
can look to see what words you're using
too much and actually there's a
fantastic book that came out last year
called dryers english and benjamin
dreyer
gives people i think it's right at the
beginning of the book
asks people to excise these particular
phrases from their
language and you can search on those
phrases i actually occasionally will do
an audit of my the language i'm using in
a book just to see what words am i using
a lot just give me the word frequency
it'll scrivener will give you the word
frequency for every single word you've
used in an entire document you can find
out if you're using the word
particularly and
if you are then you know if you've used
it 462 times maybe you need to reduce
that and the other cool thing is you
know stephen king talks about this is is
reduction of adverbs and i don't write i
am writing fiction but i haven't
released any fiction and and that's been
a really helpful tool for me as well is
just checking for adverbs and clearing
out the adverbs checking for dumb things
that i tend to use in my language that
don't need to be there yeah i use one of
my current afflictions
it's like some allergic
some food allergy that won't go away is
that said like statement statement
statement that said comma
actually the word that
the word that is an achilles heel for me
if you look through your document or
your whatever it is you're writing you
could probably remove 95
of the word that
just try the sentence without the word
the other big thing that i learned as a
journalist that i learned from my editor
and it's one of the smartest things i've
ever heard and i now use the give other
people this advice all the time is if
you're writing like an op-ed piece or a
short essay your last paragraph is
probably your better first paragraph
because people tend to take a long time
to get to the point and then it's really
clearly and beautifully elucidated in
their you know articulated in their the
end so i work with a group called the
op-ed project which is helping elevate
diverse voices to getting people to own
their expertise and write op-eds because
you know a while ago we figured out that
op-eds were being written by white men
so how can we get other voices in there
and that's almost always the first piece
of advice i give my mentees at the op-ed
project which is look at your last
paragraph move it up to the top and just
see i bet you your piece works better
that's great advice are there any
writers who immediately come to mind
non-fiction they could be fiction also
but outside of stephen king
for structure or other characteristics
where you're like wow okay
this is someone to pay attention to or
this is someone who really impresses the
hell out of me
there was a woman that named julie
lithgot haines she has a great ted talk
about her book her first book which is
called how to raise an adult
tricky things about julie lithgod haim's
little back story is that julie and i
wrote basically the same books at the
same time mine was supposed to come out
first and hers was supposed to go on
second and then i had my head injury and
it flip-flopped
julie and i also shared a student i
taught a girl in high school who went on
to stanford and julie was the freshman
dean at stanford and so we were
introduced through our student julie and
i decided early on that the worst thing
we could do was compete with each other
and the best thing we could do was be
each other's biggest cheerleader that
people who can afford one book can
probably afford two and so that's been
our mo ever since her second book was a
book called real american
and i expected julie to write a straight
up
memoir and i was super excited because
i'm like i'm all in tell me julie i'll
read anything you write
and she wrote it in the most
some of it was like it was like prose
poetry and it was she taught me to be
brave with that book so now every once
in a while when i'm writing something i
think oh just think about real american
think about what julie did there
a her publisher let her do it because it
was so good they had to admit that she
was doing something kind of magic
and be brave
and don't think oh you know my editor is
just not going to go for this because
it's different and there was another
book actually called half a life by
dare oh shoot this is why you should
never mention books until you're
positive you have the author in their
head
um
half a life it came out a long time ago
like i don't know 15 years ago and it
came out and it has a lot of empty space
in the book because it has to because
that's part of the darren strauss half
life by darren strauss d-a-r-i-n yeah
and he did some really cool things
narratively and with with empty space in
that book and you say well what do you
mean with empty space in that book and
he
allowed for
room because he had you know it was
about the fact that he hit and killed a
girl when she was riding her bicycle and
he was in a car when he was 17. and so
half a life is about that and there
needed to be empty space in the book
because there was empty space and anyway
so i i look to people like that i also
have authors that i look to as my
question is empty space do you mean
actual empty space on the page
i see so the actual visual layout of the
pros
there was
a chapter where it was like two or three
lines and then empty space for a page
and then the back of a page and then it
was just little things that make me
think oh it doesn't always have to look
the same you know julie
they allowed her to use an interesting
and different font that freaked me out
at first and then realized oh no wait
this is perfect
you know
prose poetry memoir
no but it totally worked and it was
great and darren's use of space
this does require that you have an
editor who
can get on that sort of place with you
but i also have authors that
i need as an expert voice i talk about
this on the podcast that i host
is that i'm big into dissecting other
people's work to figure out what works
and what doesn't and sometimes i as
especially when i'm first searching for
my expert voice i will keep copies of
books on my desk that are written by
people who are not afraid to tell the
truth
not afraid of people coming after them
not afraid of
being the expert and when i'm feeling
weak on a given writing day i'll pick
those books up and read them so that i
can feel strong you know who does a
great job of that for me is mary carr
oh my god mary carr
yeah yeah so good and so funny and so
zero [ __ ] given uh i mean it's
she and she's a real
artist i mean she's a she's a she's an
artist and a crafts woman if that makes
any sense she combines the two like she
knows how to put in motion the carpentry
of writing
just like stephen king
i believe they know each other i think
but yeah stephen king has a mastery of
grammar and yet she's also
very good at experimentation and
especially good at telling the truth i
think she's just
fantastic yeah i think it's really
really important to have people like
that that you look at and you either say
as and actually stephen king talks about
this and on writing you either look at
that and you go ah [ __ ] i could never be
that good i mean
how does that person even
do this how do they make me feel these
things and that could be aspirational
but again i also as he says in his book
i think it's important also to read bad
books because
for someone especially because
i think it's been really important for
me especially when i was writing gift of
failure and i was i was having a crisis
of confidence it was really important
for me to go out there and look at these
books that are on the shelf that are
crap and i know i can do better than
that and that also pushes me to
put the best work i can put out there
because i can do better than this and
this book got published how did that
book get published and my editor is
saying that my book is unpublishable i
can do better than this
yeah you can even go down the new york
times bestseller list and find some
stuff that is very very i don't say
poorly written but that is not going to
it's going to inspire confidence as
opposed to intimidate
and i think maybe i've been reading too
many good books
because
i've been feeling terrible about myself
i read little big little comma big by i
want to say the author's name is john
crowley this is from memory it's this
incredible fantastical
novel that is one of those tour de force
this just display of virtuosity that
left me just wanting to forget i ever
saw a writing implement so yeah maybe
it's time to read some some very
mediocre bad books when you read bad
books is there a genre that you like
where you're like even if this is shitty
i'm gonna enjoy it oh yeah if someone
can just carry me along in the story and
i just want to find i'll stick with a
lot i will be fairly quick to give
something up if i feel like it's a waste
of my time because there's just too many
good books out there to read but a good
thriller where there's some clunky
dialogue or there's some clunky
descriptive language if there's a really
really good plot going i'll stick with
it oh you know that's it and plus i do a
lot of my listening since since my head
injury i have a few lasting things that
from that
my time reading on a screen or a page is
somewhat limited so i
reserve that for work and i listen to
most of my sort of recreational stuff
and also i can't sit still i'm really
hyper so
it allows me to listen to something and
do something at the same time so i can
be like clearing brush in the woods and
listening to an amazing book that has me
off in another world and
i was just listening to just this past
weekend i was really i really loved jody
p cult's book the book of two ways it
took me to egypt and it took me to
academia and it took me to all these
places and i'm you know clearing brush
and there is no greater delight than
that i think to be transported
uh do you have enough time for me to ask
you one or two more questions and then
we'll wrap up does that work okay yeah
of course
so we talked a lot about favorite
failure and failures which led into this
discussion of writing which was great
best investments this could be an
investment of time
of money
of energy where you look back
outside of things we've already talked
about we're like wow okay that really
was a a formative or sort of
disproportionately important thing that
i allocated x to or decided to commit to
in whatever way
does anything come to mind for you
yeah i mean there are the easy answers
to this which is you know if my kids
want to buy a book they can always buy
the book or you know i'm fortunate
enough that we can do that but what i've
come to realize in the past couple of
years that
investing in the things that my kids are
interested in investing personally in
the things that my kids are interested
in whether or not they actually interest
me
has been an incredible learning
experience so even stuff that like for a
while there my kid when he was little or
my younger kid he was really into
crystals and i think it came out of
crystal skulls and aliens and stuff but
then it morphed into just crystals
generally and like healing crystals my
husband is a physician i'm an infectious
diseases physician and a medical
ethicist i'm an academic too and you
know way too much education so my first
instinct was well that's kind of woo-woo
for me but instead i said will you teach
me about that because i don't know
anything about that and
that led to
him going on speaking trips with me and
finding all of the crystal stores we
could find within a 100 mile radius or
now he produce my younger son produces
digital music
the music he produces is not music that
i would ever listen to on my own
but asking him to teach me about how you
use fl studio how you're using those
serum patches that you're putting into
your thing and then
we started watching youtube videos we
watched this guy named adam neely who
does music theory videos on youtube he
is
fantastic so we watch his name again his
name is adam neely n-e-e-l-y he is just
watch a couple of his videos in fact
even if i'm gonna i'm gonna say this and
you're gonna not believe me
he has one on and this is gonna most of
it is like really academic stuff but he
does one and his mom happens to be in it
too because she's a voice teacher her
name is kate
on
this one song that celine dion sings and
why this one key change
is at the heart of what makes people
feel in music
first of all i'm like celine dion no
thank you but i watched this with my son
i was wrapped and adam neely has a band
called sun sungazer
and you know as you well know
no music has been live for the past
people just haven't been doing live
music for the past year and a half and
so
i found out that sun gazer was going
back on a very sort of limited tour run
just to get in front of a few audiences
and so
we pulled some funds and we flew to
washington dc just to watch sun gazer
play this person that we'd been watching
someone that my son really admired
he plays jazz edm so like jazz but also
electronic
not my bag
but
we'd been learning about it for the past
18 months and so i could appreciate it i
could understand what adam knew was
doing what the musicians were doing with
their music and more than anything else
my kid knows that i
respect him enough
to put myself out there
for things that are important to him
that investment has been one of the most
important things my older son is an
economist do i want to learn about
economics
i know i do not want to learn about
economics but
letting him teach me about economic
theory has been one of the best
investments of my time and effort i
could ever give
that is a great answer and great
inspiration too plus
bonus i have been looking for a good way
to learn about music theory that won't
make me
want to dive head first through
a stained glass window so yeah adam
really makes music very interesting i'm
interested also listen to another
youtube producer called polyphonic i
don't actually know his real name
polyphonic and adam neely but adam neely
is really cool he's a bass player he
went to berkeley school of music his
videos are fascinating because they take
one concept
and explain how that concept makes music
as special as it is and he's just he's
really cool he's really fascinating to
watch
i'll check it out all right i'm going to
ask a question that
is sometimes dead end and i will i will
take all the blame for that
but we'll try it nonetheless that is the
billboard question so metaphorically
speaking if you add a billboard it could
be a push notification to phones if if
there's some environmental visual
objection to billboards to get a message
a quote a question and image anything
out to many many people
everyone in the u.s let's say apolitical
what might you put on that billboard two
things number one not two answers two
things number one did you know that
billboards are not allowed in vermont so
it is really
striking the minute you leave vermont if
i take the ferry over to plattsburgh
from burlington
oh my god billboards are ugly they are
so ugly they're horrifying
this is the the thing that i would put
on the billboard is essentially what i
do like as a teacher as a writer as
someone who works with kids and adults
in recovery and that's just the question
did you make someone feel seen or heard
today
that's our job i mean i think as human
beings there's no more important thing
we do as make someone else feel seen or
heard especially when they're it's most
needed
i love that and i also love that vermont
has no billboards i did not know that
signage
even if you look at like uh you know
fast food restaurants signage is
incredibly tightly regulated here it
cannot be ugly
so it's it's awfully nice go vermont
good for you if you had
a and you may already have a reminder
like a sticky note on your computer or
on your refrigerator or on your mirror
if it couldn't include your answer
if it couldn't be your answer for the
billboard what might it be i actually
they're behind me one of them is behind
me and it says hold on hey grab it
okay
one is from a researcher named larry
steinberg lawrence steinberg he wrote a
book called age of opportunity about
adolescence
and this one is protect when you must
but permit when you can
and that one that's my um
that's my parenting mantra but then this
is when i was teaching
10th grade one of my students wrote this
quote on a piece of paper because she
thought i might like it she was correct
she's now a mother of two and you know
anyway
it's the heraclitus quote you could not
step twice into the same rivers for
other waters are ever flowing onto you
and it just helps me remember that
no matter what i screw up no matter how
i screw up no matter
what that there are different waters
tomorrow i mean it comes back to this
you know if i screw up my recovery if
someone else screws up their recovery if
my kid screws up tomorrow ever you know
new waters are going to be flowing over
us and so it's going to be really
important for us to walk into those
waters from a place of
newness and acceptance and learning
so those are my two you've pulled my
attention to the wall behind you i've
been focusing on your i've been focusing
on your face
and i can't
miss
absolutely
with not underlined
what is the background what's the back
story on that i think i think i asked
my husband a question or a kid asked my
kid my husband a question and the answer
was absolutely not i just thought it was
funny and so i put it up there i'm not a
sentimental person and so the fact that
i have a wall full of things that mean
something to me these are the things
that mean a lot to me and it's because
and i have to tip it slightly this way
so you can see there's a picture right
here and this is my father's office when
i was little he was an industrial
designer and he had a like a 20-foot
high wall
in his office that had just stuff from
all over the world that he had collected
that people had given him
things that meant a lot to him and
when i was little i said someday when i
have an office i want a wall like that i
want important things on my wall and
this these are the important things on
my wall and every single thing on this
wall for the most part anyway has a
story so
it's amazing i mean it looks like just
for people who don't have the visual if
you imagine
you had and hopefully this description
doesn't offend you in any way wow it's
tall too so if you imagined you went
into
your childhood desk yeah your your
grandparents desk yeah and
also went on like a scavenger hunt
outside and stole a few things and you
took everything and put it on the floor
so that you could take a photograph from
the top but then you turned it and it
was on a wall behind you that is what
this looks like are there any other
items here that you would like to
explain that are particularly meaningful
yeah so i made that particularly
particularly i know i made that in
second grade so i've carried that around
with me my whole life that's my dad what
is that this is a cherry pie duh
it's oh
obviously um this uh someone gave me
this that's power girl because someone
said i remind them of power girl and i'm
like well that's badass so she needs to
be up there um when i first started
writing for the new york times there was
no budget for our art so we used to have
to make pictures if you go back to my
earliest columns at the new york times
the pictures are
with literary action figures playmobil
figures and lego figures for the most
part and so a bunch of my literary
figures are up here because they're from
my new york times articles my kids harry
potter wands are on here because when
people ask me
questions about parenting my answer is
often you know i wish i had a magic wand
to wave to say you know let me just fix
that for you but i can't
this picture right here behind me this
is my law school graduation and this was
my best friend mary moore parham
and she died by suicide in 1999 and the
scholarship fund at santa the reason my
entire salary goes 100 into a
scholarship fund for young people is
because of her it's named for her she
worked with people who needed who had
mental health issues and just needed
help and didn't know where else to get
it and so
that's where that comes from for her but
there's one thing i am embarrassed about
up here there's a um
this ring up here there's a carousel on
martha's vineyard in edgartown
and as you go around you grab and you
know the saying of grabbing the brass
ring there's a brass ring and if you win
if you get that then you win something
my dad took
a long time ago took a couple of the
rings from that carousel and has felt
guilty about it his entire life and
returned them all to sent them in an
envelope back to edgartown back to the
carousel back to the town actually i
think except for this one he found when
they moved and so at some point i'm
going to have to take it i want to take
it in person to edgartown to return it
to its rightful owner
the brass ring
i'm sorry to hear about it not one of
the brass ones though it's actually i
think one of the steel ones it's not if
it was a brass one i would have already
returned it
yeah well i'm sorry to hear about your
friend
she's it's she's it's cool she's uh it's
her it was just the 20th anniversary
obviously of her death but she is
she's the reason that i make my life my
argument honestly she's one of the main
reasons i do that because that's what
she did
well thank you for sharing all of that
of course and
jessica this has been a lot of fun we're
recording this pretty late for those who
are unaware we're doing we're doing this
in the evening
and
i appreciate you rallying to
spend the time is there anything else
you would like to
mention anything else you would like to
share ask of listeners before we wrap up
the latest book is the addiction
inoculation subtitle raising healthy
kids and a culture of dependence people
can find you at jessica leahy l-a-h-e-y
dot com and on twitter at jess leahy
instagram teacher leahy and we'll
include links to all the other social on
the podcast and sana it's still as well
in the show notes uh but is there
anything else that you would like to add
before we wrap up
yeah i think this year has been you know
this past year and a half i had to try
to release a book during a pandemic and
i'm very lucky that i get to release a
book but i had to release a book during
a pandemic and especially on a topic
that's really scary i mean talking about
failure in kids talking about addiction
in kids is really really scary and i
just want to reassure parents that
avoiding these conversations is not how
they get better and they don't go away
just because we avoid having them and so
i promise if you do choose to pick up
either one of my books i come at this
stuff from a place of compassion and
love i do not want anyone to feel any
shame
but
for our kids benefit i hope that people
consider thinking about whether it's
picking up one of my books or picking up
peggy orenstein's books girls and sex
and boys and sex and thinking about how
we actually have these conversations
that scare us because they're really
important conversations to have and they
don't just go away when we avoid them
not only do they not go away
[Laughter]
things can get a lot worse yes i really
thank you for
bringing attention to
raising awareness around these
conversations but then also providing
people with the tools to have these
conversations i also feel a huge debt of
gratitude by the way i need to thank in
the addiction inoculation
this guy brian and this woman georgia
play huge parts in those books and they
told me all of the horrifying
joyful
scary parts of their stories and then as
i said gave me their real names to use
because they said both of them said this
in in various iterations
these experiences were so horrifying i
mean georgia lost a child and was
homeless and was in prison and these
experiences are only worth something if
we learn something from them and if
their stories can help someone else then
they were going to be worth it and so i
owe so much to brian and georgia for
sharing their stories for this book
well thank you very much jessica for
taking the time thank you and by the way
you would be a fantastic ninth grade
teacher because
you're curious and that's what makes you
a great interviewer what also is what
would make you a great ninth grade
teacher
oh thank you i'm uh you would be really
good about matching some plans yeah
we'll see where we'll see where it goes
you know but you know what my dream is
my dream
is to open a recovery high school if you
ever get a chance watch a show on mtv it
was only like four episodes called 16
and in recovery and it was based on a
school on the north shore of
massachusetts of recovery high school so
a school for kids who are you know
struggling with their sobriety and
addiction issues but we need one in
burlington vermont and one of the things
i would really like to do is open one
someday so that's something that's out
there is a thing so maybe you could come
be a ninth grade teacher and teach kids
in recovery
there we go
never him
ninth grade
never say never never say never i'm
getting you know i might get fatigued to
this podcasting game
and they could co-exist also well thank
you very much and to everybody
listening
we will have show notes linking to
everything including gift of failure
addiction inoculation all of the
websites and social and all the
resources also and people we refer to in
this podcast at team.blogforthepodcast
and until next time thank you for tuning
in
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.blog friday type that into your
browser tim.log slash friday drop in
your email and you'll get the very next
one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance i recommended it
in fact in the four hour body this is
more than ten years ago and i did not
get paid to do so with approximately 75
vitamins minerals and whole foods
sourced ingredients you'd be very
hard-pressed to find a more
nutrient-dense and comprehensive formula
on the market it has multivitamins
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases if i miss anything
i'm not aware of of course i focus on
nutrient-dense meals to begin with
that's the basis but athletic greens
makes it easy to get a lot of nutrition
when whole foods aren't readily
available both travel packets i always
have them in my bag when i'm zipping
around right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
you'll receive up to a year's supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
this episode is brought to you by block
five block five is building a bridge
between cryptocurrencies and traditional
financial and wealth management products
they're creating innovative products to
advance the digital asset ecosystem for
both individual and institutional
investors and its platform now manages
more than 12 billion in assets full
disclosure i became excited enough about
this company that i ended up becoming an
investor moving on block fi that's block
fi offers a wide spectrum of services
and i'll mention just a few here first
their block fi rewards visa signature
credit card provides an easy way to earn
more bitcoin because you can earn 3.5 in
bitcoin back on all purchases in your
first three months and 1.5 percent
forever after with no annual fee second
block by also its clients that would be
you easily buy or sell cryptocurrencies
including but not limited to they have a
wide selection bitcoin ether litecoin
and pax g as well as usd that's united
states dollars based stable coins
including usdc gusd and pax blockbuy
aggregates liquidity to offer seamless
trade execution and pricing blockfy also
offers instant ach so you can move funds
onto the platform and immediately start
trading on their platform you will soon
be able to trade with ach meaning you'll
be able to buy cryptocurrencies directly
with your bank account and there's a lot
more coming so check it out for a
limited time you can earn a crypto bonus
of 15 to 250 dollars in value again for
a limited time you can earn a crypto
bonus of fifteen dollars to two hundred
fifty dollars in value when you open a
new account get started today at
blockfy.com tim and use code tim at
signup that's
dot
blockfi.comckfi.com
tim and code
[Applause]